[Música]
Hola Aquí comienza la crónica de medio
ambiente yo soy María Clara calle uno de
los planes alternos de las petroleras y
las compañías de gas y carbón es el
plástico al refinar los combustibles
fósiles también salen polímeros que son
a su vez la base para producir
materiales plásticos pero así las
compañías se involucran de nuevo en uno
de los negocios más contaminantes del
planeta la fundación
publicó este año su segundo índice de
fabricantes de residuos plásticos y
según las estadísticas a 2021 la
humanidad produjo 6 millones de
toneladas más de basuras de plásticos de
un solo uso que en 2019 con un total de
130 millones de toneladas métricas con
un dato interesante tan solo 100
empresas petroquímicas producen más del
90% de los plásticos de un solo uso de
todo el mundo y estas son responsables
de la mitad de ese plástico la petrolera
estadounidense exxon móvil es la que más
desechos genera con esta clase de
plástico con seis millones de toneladas
métricas seguida de la China sinopec y
la también estadounidense Down en el
ranking hay Solo dos empresas
latinoamericanas alpec una compañía
mexicana dedicada a los químicos y
braskem una industria petroquímica de
Brasil y por Francia está total energys
además de las basuras el plástico es uno
de los responsables del calentamiento
global la octe dice que representó el
3,4% de los gases de efecto invernadero
del planeta y minder room Calcula que
sólo los plásticos de un solo uso
emitieron 460 millones de toneladas
métricas equivalentes de CO2 más o menos
lo mismo que los gases contaminantes de
Reino Unido estas 20 compañías
petroquímicas son las más contaminantes
al producir polímeros concinopec a la
cabeza seguido por la tailandesa
indorama y luego exon móvil
hablamos con uno de los autores del
índice de plásticos de minder Lauren
keyman nos explicó desde amsterdam que
las compañías siguen siendo casi las
mismas entre 2019 y 2021 y que tan solo
un par producen también plástico
reciclable Esto fue lo que nos dijo
cuando hicimos este ejercicio hace dos
años en efecto vimos que el 99% del
plástico de un solo uso vino de
combustibles fósiles dos años después
cuando actualizamos el índice el
resultado es que todavía el 98% viene de
combustibles fósiles es una mejoría
mínima y la gran mayoría sigue
proveniendo de estos combustibles lo que
significa que solo el 2% viene de
plástico reciclados así la mayoría de
los plásticos de un solo uso siguen
siendo descartados y terminan en
nuestros océanos hay alguna transición
ocurriendo en la parte superior de la
cadena de suministros con un par de
actores que están produciendo polímeros
reciclados a gran escala la gran mayoría
no está cumpliendo algunos de sus
compromisos
El problema es que producir plástico
reciclados es más costoso y muchas veces
requiere más tecnología que producir
plásticos vírgenes que son los que
vienen de combustibles fósiles Pero hay
soluciones explica la importancia de las
políticas y de la reducción en el
consumo y la producción
el problema fundamental aquí es la
economía los plásticos de combustibles
fósiles son muy baratos de producir y
los de materiales reciclados muy
costosos las únicas soluciones que
tenemos según nuestra investigación son
las políticas la intervención en las
políticas es clave y lo que realmente se
necesita para lograr un balance
económico entre plásticos de
combustibles fósiles y los reciclados
y primero que todo creemos que reducir
el consumo Es un punto vital en la
cadena de valor y también se necesita
bajar la producción hay mucho plástico
muchos químicos en los materiales y no
necesitamos tanto
y a propósito de las políticas Hay un
plan para reducir la producción de
plásticos desde noviembre de 2022 la
mayoría de países están negociando el
que sería el primer tratado
internacional jurídicamente vinculante
sobre la contaminación plástica en la
segunda sesión que se realizó en mayo en
París acordaron escribir el primer
borrador del pacto pero aún hay unas
profundas divisiones países con
industrias fuertes en hidrocarburos se
oponen por ejemplo a que haya las mismas
reglas obligatorias para todos una idea
que respaldan 135 de los 180 estados
miembros Gustavo mesa cuadra Velázquez
es el presidente del comité
intergubernamental de esta negociación
nos que las discusiones se dividieron en
dos grupos de trabajo y en uno de ellos
debatieron las medidas de control ha
habido posiciones en favor de establecer
algunos límites a la producción
de algunos polímeros también ha habido
propuestas para
limitar o poner algún tiempo en el cual
se debe dejar de producir algunos
plásticos como aquellos plásticos que se
llaman problemáticos de un oso uso de
corta duración o de un solo uso ese tipo
de discusiones
llevaron a que en algunos casos hubiera
coincidencias pero en algunos casos
diferencias algunos países favorecían
estas limitaciones algunos países este
se orientaban más por por dejar espacio
a que los países
discutieran eso en decisiones que
tuvieran que darse a nivel nacional a
pesar de las dificultades Gustavo Meza
cuadra pierde la esperanza en que se
logrará un acuerdo sobre plásticos para
2024 y que han dado grandes pasos para
ello y ahora Este era el objetivo que
haya un mandato para elaborar el primer
borrador y fue una semana difícil de
negociación primera vez que veíamos las
posiciones de todos los países en los
diversos temas que implica este acuerdo
y por eso fue difícil en algunos temas
procedimentales pero finalmente el
último día se logró un consenso para
encargar al presidente en este caso a mi
persona con el apoyo de la secretaría a
elaborar Este primer borrador así
llegamos al final de La Crónica de medio
ambiente Vean este y todos los capítulos
en France 24.com